hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara just saw and I just
went saw detective Pikachu and it was
[Music]
I've never watched a movie where I said
verbally said ah so many times going
into this I knew I was gonna like it
the trailers did it so much good just
looked funny
it looked entertaining looked just good
CGI's the animation whatever it is I
don't actually know the term alright but
it looked amazing if you didn't catch my
Tamara's never seen yesterday I posted
an episode with my brother where we did
Pokemon the first movie Mewtwo strikes
again or Strikes Back or something but
watch that for the first time and gave a
little history of our pokemons
background wasn't really allowed to have
the card until later in life played the
games a toy damn that n64 cartridge I
still have you you're worn out I love
you played a lot of the games growing up
and watch the show when we could when we
were younger we weren't allowed to and
then kind of got it past mom as we grew
up never saw that movie though and I was
excited to go into this I'm not the
biggest Pokemon fan but I'm definitely a
Pokemon fan eighty years sometimes I
think it's better to go into things not
that you can help it but it better to go
into things when you're not such a
massive fan because it's so easy to get
upset by smaller details when you're
like just the biggest fan so thankfully
I'm just like a medium midline Road
Pokemon fan that being said I loved this
movie I thought that it was awesome it
had some really good Pokemon humor it
was so heartfelt and really sweet and
honestly somber at some points I think
the acting was great I think Pikachu
stole the show Ryan Reynolds knocked out
of the park with this one
his voice is always in everyone's mind
gonna be Deadpool I
he's just that's just his thing that's
where he really came out like a shining
star into the light of the world and
brightened it up but it didn't scream
Deadpool to me she's crazy because
Deadpool is mostly a guy in a mask
where you don't see a face and this is
just like this little CGI Pikachu so you
know you would think but no it really
played off as its own thing I think
that's because most of the humor was
Pikachu pokémon humor vs Deadpool humor
there were a few Ryan Reynolds Oaks in
there for sure but that kind of I don't
it worked it totally worked he did an
outstanding job in this the story while
not at all what I was expecting going
into it was what you should expect going
into it it's more of a detective e type
film which is the term for it
detective II type film you know the
classic detective detective II type it's
more of that than it is a pokeymon fill
like there's not that much catching
pokémon with pokeballs
and training Pokemon and Pokemon battles
there are those aspects to it but not
nearly as much as I imagined there would
be and I think for a lot of people going
in that aren't Pokemon fans it's a
really good thing and for someone like
me who's like a middle-of-the-road
Pokemon fan it was great for me as well
though I wouldn't have minded seeing
more of that classic og Pokemon style I
think for massive fans that might be an
issue I really don't know it wasn't an
issue for me at all but I could see
wanting that genuinely wanting more of
that it's literally in the name
detective Pikachu so you get kind of
what it says you're gonna get which is
nice this story was really sweet like I
said very heartfelt very funny it made
sense I think the only thing really that
I think would have made it just even
better for me is there's one character
where everything they do comes
incredibly easy to
them and it's fun to watch she's awesome
but I think everything is a little too
easily to our journalist friend and
again while it's fun and super great to
watch and while she has the best Pokemon
sidekick who knew that you could love
Psyduck this much I sure did not but now
I do I'm a firm believer I took is my
jam outside of that though it just it
comes so easy if there's like a problem
you go to her and then it's immediately
solved and so that's maybe could have
been developed a little bit more but it
also feels like again while not being
like a you know catching and training
and fighting Pokemon kind of deal it
feels like an episode of the show where
it's kind of like you know it's easily
resolved there's still amazing action in
it honestly some film like there's a
scene out in a forest and it's so
exciting a really great and you get one
of your more heartfelt moments then
straight back in action it's really
great so outside of that one small
detail which you could argue just kind
of plays into the episodic nosov it
being you know Ash Ketchum and easily
finding like a really neat way to go
about things I think it's just really
fun I also love that we got our sonic
well I won't say our sonic trailer we
got a sonic trailer and not even a huge
Sonic fan way more of a pokemon fan than
I am a Sonic fan but I know people are
livid about this in the trailer is like
the small amount of footage we've seen
for it so far there is a joke about him
getting like oh I got 9 million steps in
today and I'm Sonic the Hedgehog and
then in this we get a Steps joke from
Pikachu and it's so Philip being funny
and like man they've done so much so so
so so so so so much better already than
just that one trailer but even funny
that like in the
it even made it in but this is doing a
better job than that
I do love all the comparisons between
Sonic and Pikachu Pikachu is a perfectly
designed character I think the best part
of the film outside of Pikachu as a
whole this specific small Pokemon is
just the Pokemon in general are just
super fun to see I won't mention any
that weren't in the trailer but oh those
Bulbasaur amazing so freaking cute
Psyduck like I said just top dog
top-notch psidog psidog psidog what's up
damn you just yeah you get some really
really cool Pokemon and they look great
and you feel like you're living amongst
them it feels like the show in that
aspect and the games in that aspect
we're like you're walking around there's
Pokemon there super freaking cool
without giving too much away there's
some big-ass Pokemon of this and I
leaned over to my brother who I saw the
movie with it I was like calling it now
this is better than Godzilla's ever
gonna be there's a climate change joke
that's just fun for the whole family
if there's also a point that really
reminded me of a Super Smash Brothers
level they're like jumping on big
balloon it's just it's fun it's so cool
it's original it feels fresh and new but
it still feels nostalgic what you want
it was so much fun I super recommend
this movie I really enjoyed justice
Smith's character I posted on Twitter
that I really liked it which Ryan
Reynolds liked which is just that's a
fun thing though that doesn't make me
worried for his mental health get off of
Twitter man it's not worth it you were
great
gut believe but I treated about it and
somebody said that it was too somber and
the justice Smith's character in
particular was too like down in the
dumps the whole time I guess I see what
you're saying
because sure he was I mean he's lost
both of his parents but would you find
out that's kind of a spoiler you you
find that out in like the first five
minutes so whatever it's not it's not
interval to the story it is integral to
the story okay
he's definitely somber and then he's not
there's like a clear turning point for
him and it's a really sweet moment
between him and Pikachu there's a clear
turning point I think for that character
and it's really fun to see that growth I
don't know this is character that we
didn't know before this and at the end I
feel like I know him
and I think it was done really well yeah
I didn't feel that but I could see where
you're coming from with that I don't
know I don't really know quite what
people are going to say negative about
this movie I think it does its job it
does justice to the characters and I
love it I also love that Pikachu sits on
Tim's shoulder and that's how I done my
shoulder in the whole time I'm just
squealing at how I kiss Pikachu and I'm
going to try to get him to do it right
now will you pair it please fine
just love and affection and some cameos
in my videos once in a while okay I pay
for your life I would give this eight
out of ten hair flips just because it
made me happy and man that's the kind of
content we need you know what I mean and
I mean it thank you so much for watching
I will see you all next week with John
wicks three hmm okay thank you I wanna
be very best
[Music]